No.
The subject of today's lecture is hedging.
So this is the sweat hedge funds do.
It's what almost everyone on Wall Street
does nowadays. At least to some extent,
say half the people I'm lost
where you do it nowadays. Uh,
it was hardly done at all in the past.
So first of all,
just to mention what a hedge fund is.
I Hedge Fund is a firm that manages money.
And why is it different from any
other firm that manages money? Well,
the definition of hedge fund
basically has three parts.
One is that hedge funds
hedge, okay, now, uh,
I'll say what that is in a second.
Secondly,
hedge funds use borrowed money in
addition to their investors money to buy
acids.
So they do what's called leveraging,
which is going to be an important
subject for the last few lectures of the
course. And thirdly, they charge
their investors very high fees.
That's basically the definition of a
hedge fund because they're supposed to be
so good at what they do. They can charge
high fees and still get the investors.
So what is hedging?
Hedging is the idea that you want
to cancel out some of your risks.
So for instance, you might know that
a company's not going to default,
whereas the rest, whereas the rest of
the market thinks it is going to default.
So you know the company's worth more
than the rest of the market thinks.
So you might be tempted to
buy the con the company,
but if the interest rate were to change,
say go way up and the company's paying
has constant, uh, cash payments.
If the interest rate goes way up and
the company has constant cash payments,
you could end up losing money
anyway because you know,
the present value is going to go down just
because the interest rate has gone up.
So what a hedger would do is
the hedger would say, look,
I'm relying on my expertise as a evaluator
to realize there's no default risk.
I want to bet that there's no
default risk in this company.
It's not going to default.
I don't want to bet on which way interest
rates are going to go because I don't
know which way interest
rates are going to go.
So I want to hedge myself against that.
So to take,
to take a,
sorry,
I'm just starting here at a lot of hello.
Sorry. Hard to talk when everyone
else is talking. So if, uh, if you,
um,
so what is,
what is hedging the risk mean means it
means no matter which way the risk factor
goes, you're going to still end
up with the same amount of money.
So the first person to do this,
uh,
and call himself a hedge fund was
somebody named Jones in the 1940s.
And he was a stock picker who,
which try to find the best
possible stock to buy.
So beforehand people would say,
okay, four does a great auto company.
We're going to buy Ford.
Uh,
the trouble is that Ford May in fact
turn out to be the best auto company,
but because the whole economy
collapsed, it may be that Ford, uh,
collapsed with the rest of the economy,
even though it did better than all the
other auto companies. So at Jones said is,
I'm not going to just buy Ford.
What I'm going to do is I'm going to
buy Ford and I'm going to sell General
Motors.
So that way I'm going to be betting
not on where the forward is better than
General Motors. And in addition, whether
the whole economy is going to go up,
I only want to bet on where the
Ford is better than General Motors.
So if the whole economy goes down,
Ford and General Motors,
we'll go down together.
So what you own in Ford,
you won't own something
as valuable anymore,
but what you owe by having sold general
motors short also won't be as valuable.
So you're what you've
bought and what you've sold.
We'll cancel each other out and you won't
have lost any money. On the other hand,
if Ford ends up doing
better than General Motors,
you'll have gained more with Ford,
then he'll have lost with General Motors.
So whether the economy goes up or down,
if the gap between Ford and
General Motors stays the same,
you won't lose or win money.
So you're hedged against
general changes in the economy.
You're only gonna make or lose money
depending on the spread between Ford and
General Motors.
So you've cancelled out the economy wide
risk and you're only holding one risk,
which you really think
that you've understood. So
that's what, uh, hedging is.
So I'm going to now show you that hedging
is actually a slightly delicate thing.
It's quite complicated and
we're going to learn the,
the technique of dynamic hedging.
Okay.
And why is dynamic hedging so important?
Dynamic hedging is so important because
there's so many things that can happen
in the future. And as I said, for
example, if you hold a mortgage,
you may think the mortgage
is more valuable because
you know people aren't going
to default and the rest of the economy
thinks they're going to default.
On the other hand, the value
of the mortgage will change
with the interest rate.
So you want to protect yourself
against the interest rate change,
but it's not just the interest
rate change. You know,
over 10 years or 30 years,
the life of the mortgage,
they're going to be a huge
number of interest rates changes.
There'll be a whole path of interest rate
changes and the and the mortgage will
be paying different cash flows along the
whole path and over 30 years. You know,
even if you only think
of one change a day,
there's an exponentially
growing set of changes.
So there's an exponential number of pads.
You'll never be able to
equalize your cash flows,
you would think over every single path.
They're just too many of them.
But dynamic hedging says you don't have
to equalize over every path from the
very beginning.
That is,
you don't have to hold a portfolio at
the very beginning that equalizes your
cash flows by the end on every path.
You only have to equalize your cashflow
one step at a time and then dynamically
change your hedge.
Okay?
So it's a much easier thing to hedge
than it sounds at first glance.
So I want to illustrate that because you
can't know what that means yet until we
see an example.
So let's start with a very easy thing.
Understand the world series
where we started with before.
So you have some expertise.
In fact,
there are other people besides you have
the same expertise, these other bookies.
You all know the Yankees have a 60%
chance of winning every game against the
Phillies and you,
and let's just assume for simplicity that
the world series is only going to take
a couple weeks. The interest rate is
zero over such a short period of time.
You don't care whether you get the
money now or at the end of two weeks.
It's just so long as you get it. And
secondly, um, and you can borrow or lend,
you know, zero interest over those
short number of days. And secondly,
um, you know that the
probability of winning is 60%.
Now suppose that some naive
person comes to you and says,
you know,
I'm a Phillies fan.
I want to bet at even odds that the
Phillies are going to win for $100.
So you're going to now get a payoff that's
minus a hundred dollars at the end of
game seven, assuming I counted,
right? So this is, uh, the start.
So this would be game one here.
So that's one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven. Okay.
So at the end of games, by the end of
game seven, if you played it to the,
and you would have made
$100 if the Yankees won a
majority of the games and you
would have lost $100 of the Yankees,
didn't win a majority of the Games.
So how much is that worth to you?
Well,
obviously it's worth a lot more than
$20 because if they only played one game
and the Yankees had a
60% chance of winning,
the expected payoff for the Yankees would
be of that bet for one game would be
$20 right?
Because you know,
in one game a 0.6 chance of a hundred
and appoint four chance of minus a
hundred, that gives you an
expectation of 2060 minus 40 is 20.
However,
we're playing a seven game series.
The whole point of playing along series
is that the Yankees are more likely to
win. That's, you know, the better
teams more likely to win. And in fact,
we know that the expect by doing this
backward induction calculation, uh,
we know that the expected
winnings for the Yankees is $42.
However, the Yankees, you know, you can
lose $100 if the Phillies just got lucky,
you could lose as well as when $100.
You don't want to face that risk.
So what could you do?
Well,
the simplest thing to do is to
go to another bookie and say,
I want to bet on the world series
with this other bookie and if that,
and so if the book,
he is willing to make a bet
with you for a hunt, you know,
for the whole series. Okay, so the book,
he has to be pretty sophisticated and
do the same calculation the bookie is
going to give you,
you know,
let you bet however you want
to at the right odds. Okay?
So, um, what would you do?
So here you can win a hundred.
There are only two outcomes.
You can win a hundred or you
can lose a hundred. Okay.
Now the odds of winning the game.
I forgot to say that this series,
we figured this out before.
Oh dear. What were the odds?
I hope I have another one of
these world series things. Um
Oh labor.
Okay.
So what are the odds of the Yankees
are going to win the world series?
We calculated this before.
Do you remember what it was?
Okay,
well we know some probability p times a
hundred put some probability one minus
teaching minus a hundred gives you 42.
So p times a hundred plus one minus
p times minus a hundred equals 42
approximately. That's 42, right?
So we know that uh, therefore
to p times a hundred.
Yeah.
Okay.
Two P times 100 equals 142.
So,
um,
p equals 142 over a hundred
a divide over times two,
which equals about
0.71. Okay. So you know,
so this other book you
would have calculated,
the odds are 71% that the Yankees
are going to win the world series.
And we calculated this a few classes ago,
the [inaudible] 71% chance of
winning the world series. Okay?
So if you went to another bookie who
could do this calculation, the other book,
he would be willing to give you
odds of 71% Yankees versus 39% um,
Phillies. So you could just unload this
whole bet and get $42 for sure. In fact,
what would you bet with the other guy?
What, what would, what would
you bet with the other bookie?
What would you do if you could
bet on the whole world series,
somebody suggested that he was sitting
over there at the end of the last class,
what would you do if you could bet on
the whole world series with the other
bookie,
what pat would you make?
You know that the bed is
giving you $42 on expectation.
The trouble is some of the time it's
giving you a hundred some of the time it's
giving you minus a hundred you
don't want to fix this risk.
You want to end up with $42 for
sure. Now, how can you do that?
Well if you did minus 68 here,
that would equal 42
okay.
And if you did plus a 142 here,
now it also equal 42 so could you figure
out a way of betting with the other
book?
He's 142 versus 68 you win 142 if the
Phillies win and you lose 68 if the a
Yankees win.
Yeah,
that's not 30 to 42 by the way.
MMM.
Okay.
Can you make a bet?
What would another big book he'd
be willing to give you this?
What's the answer?
The answer is yes.
How do you know the other book?
It would be willing to give you this bet.
Okay.
What is p times 50 what is p times 42
plus one minus p times 42 it's 42 what's p
times a hundred plus one minus p times
minus 100 it's also 42 so therefore
what's p times this plus
one minus p times that?
Yeah,
zero. Okay. So at the
odds p and one minus P,
this bed is perfectly fair.
So the other book,
he would say that's the odd 71% to 39%
that's exactly what these odds are.
So if,
if p times this plus one minus p times,
that is 42 and PT times this
plus one minus p times to that,
that's obviously 42 must be p times this
plus one minus p times. That is zero.
In other words, at the odds, P and
one minus P, this is a fair bet.
So the other book he ought to be able
to would give you those odds. Okay?
So that's what hedging
is in its simplest form.
We haven't had to do anything dynamic.
The guy,
some guys willing to bet on the world
series with you so you know that he's done
something wrong in his calculations.
He's got the wrong p. So you want, okay,
so you can take advantage
of the situation. You're,
you know that P is higher than he does.
On the other hand,
there's still God in the
background and luck, you know,
which might make the Phillies win.
And so you don't want to subject
yourself to that risk. So what do you do?
You Do, you take the bat,
the advantageous bet,
but you put together with
a hedging bet where you're
betting on the wrong team,
the team you think is going to lose. Okay,
but you're betting on the wrong team,
but this time it fair rods on the wrong
team and so you're transforming your
risky pay off. I'll be it with
very favorable odds. You know,
pee we just said was 0.71
you're taking your risky payoff and
turning it into a safe payoff of 42 no
matter what. That's the essence
of hedging. In order to do that,
you might have to bet the opposite way
that you think is going to turn out. Okay.
So there's principle number one.
So I'll let me pause and see if there
are any questions for that about that.
The idea is that there's something you
know that you can take advantage of,
but life is more complicated.
The knowing one thing,
knowing one thing, namely what
P is. Life also involves, um,
all kinds of other
things that might happen.
You want to insulate yourself from those
other things and concentrate entirely
on what you know about p and one minus p
and therefore assure yourself of a bed,
a 42 no matter what,
and you're taking advantage of the fact
that other people will also be able to
bet, uh, at p with you, okay? In this one,
outsider doesn't understand
that the bookies are willing to
take odds of p. He's offering odds of a
half, which are crazy. It's a big gap. 71,
29 to pee. So you can take
42 of his dollars for sure.
Okay, so now, um, let's go to,
uh, okay, so this is hedging.
It's also an arbitrage.
This is a hedging
created a pure arbitrage,
okay?
Because now that you did, in this
case, it's done even better than a,
in my example with Ford,
because you've taken now
a bet and transformed that
we're an expectation you're
going to win into a bat where
you can't possibly lose.
Okay?
Okay.
Now suppose that these other brokers
weren't as clever as you suppose that the
other bro. Okay? So that's hedging.
Now we're going to do dynamic hedging.
Suppose the other brokers,
they're not as smart as you.
They don't know how to build these trees.
They can't do backward induction.
They just know the odds are 60% that
the Yankees are going to win any game
against the Phillies.
Now what would you do?
Okay?
Okay.
You can't go to another broker and say,
I want to bet on the
whole seven game series.
The guy's going to say it's just too
complicated for me. I'm a simple man.
I make a simple living. I just do
one game bets. Tell me, you know,
I'll let you bet any game
you want. You can, you know,
you tell me what you want to bet. We'll
bet one game at a time, 60 40 odds,
the whole series. You don't as much more
complicated for me. So what could you,
is there anything you can do now?
What can you do now?
So now you have to do
something more complicated,
which is called dynamic hedging.
Okay?
So we started to talk about this
last time. So what is dying?
So what would you do?
You only now have the opportunity of
protecting yourself against bad luck by
betting one game at a time with these
other brokers. So what should you do?
Okay,
well,
let's look at this picture here.
You know that this bet of plus 100 minus
a hundred by doing backward induction
is worth 42.
So if you were a trader,
a hedge fund manager,
you would be marking your
position at 42 you're expecting.
Now you've just made a trade,
which you know,
on average it's going to make you
$42. Of course, if you had bad luck,
you could end up losing a hundred dollars.
You know,
which means you're going to go out of
business, you're going to be fired,
your name's going to be in the newspaper,
you're going to be probably sued
by your investors, okay. Or,
or you can, um, we haven't been sued
by any investors, or you can, uh,
you, you, you know, you might make
$100. Now you don't want to face that.
You want to hedge yourself,
protect yourself, so you're
going to make the money,
for sure. Now, some people don't hedge.
They say, you know, when you hedge,
you're betting against yourself and
you know, something bad can happen.
The hedge might go
negative, right? I mean,
it may be that the Yankees win just as
you think, but because of you've hedged,
your not going to get $100,
you only can get $42.
So the essence of hedging is you give
something up on the upside to get
something on the downside.
Some people don't like hedging because
they're giving something up. Okay?
So you're giving something up.
The point is you're getting something
back on the downside and you're making it
so you're locking in your profit.
So hedging is a good thing.
So people who don't hedge,
I think they're just very simple minded.
So there are a lot of people who
still don't hedge. But anyway,
there's a revolution in financial
fought in the last 30 years,
anticipated by Ford.
But we didn't really get,
people didn't really catch on until
the 70s, uh, that you should have.
So how can you hedge this if you can
only bet one time, one game at a time?
That was the question we dealt with
last time. What should you do? Well,
you see the principles we've
learned so far. Tell us what to do.
You started here thinking on average
you're going to make $42 you should be
marking your position,
you know correctly that it's worth
$42 now if you win the first game,
you know you're at a big advantage,
the Yankees are up again,
and by backward induction,
we know that then your position
will be worth $64 okay?
If you lose,
your position will be worth $8.
Now what is 60% of 64 and f plus 40%
of nine it's 40 to 60% of 64 is 38.4
okay,
so you're 42 and you could go
with 60% probability to 60 wife,
can't remember the number,
64 or down to 0.9 40% sorry,
I'm getting senile.
Nine with 40% probability.
So 60% times that is a 38.4 plus 40% of
nine his point is a 3.6 and the two add
up to 42 okay. So that's why the, okay,
so to say that the value's worth 42
how did you get the 42 we were doing
backward induction,
we took 60% of that plus 40% of that and
we got 42 so if you're marking yourself
to market after the first game of the
series, you'll have to say to the world,
admit to the world that you're either now
worth $64 or you've gotten crushed and
you're down to $8 that already
might get you fired. You know,
going from 42 to eight
that's a pretty drastic Wass.
So even the first day you're, you'd
be, if you have to mark to market,
you're going to be revealing to
the world that you screwed up.
And younger position only eight
you've told all your investors,
you've done this brilliant thing there.
They're up $42 the next day you're going
to have to tell them, well, I'm sorry,
you're only up $8 they're going to
be very upset. So what would you do?
You know what to do?
What would you do?
What hedge? Good answer.
How would you hedge?
Right?
So you'd go,
MMM,
so what? What? What'd you say? You go
last time.
So here, this is minus, not
and all this is nine, right?
So you'd go plus 33 minus 22 okay,
so that's equal to 42 and that's also
equal to 42 so how can you do this at a
fair? Is it fair odds
to do this? Well, yes,
it has to be fair odds to do this because
60% of 64 plus 40% of nine is indeed
40 to 60% of 42 plus 40% of 42 obviously
it's 42 so therefore the difference,
60% of this plus 40% of that must be
zero. So in other words, it's fair rods.
And sure enough, this is obviously
three to two odds, right?
60 40 means you're betting at three
to two dogs. That's three to two odds.
So it is a fair bet.
So the other book,
he who's willing to bed at three to two
odds, it's going to give you this bet.
So again, you, you think
the Yankees are going to,
when you go to the other and you
make a bet with the naive Philly fan,
you're betting the Yankees are going to,
when you go to your broker friend
and you bet against your Yankees,
you know you're,
you're putting down 22 you're going to
lose $22 if the Yankees win and win 33 if
the Phillies win,
you're betting against yourself.
But of course you're betting against
yourself to a smaller extent.
Then you're betting against the other
guy and therefore you still locked in $42
okay,
so now we don't have to go any further.
You would only be confusing to go further.
And I usually go further and then,
so it's just be complicated.
If you can do something once,
you can do it many times.
So you can by making
the right hedging bet,
you can lock in a profit
of 42 up here and up here,
okay?
But that means you can lock it in going
forward until the very end because you
can keep repeating that
hedge over and over again.
Okay? So maybe I'd better go one step
further. You don't really believe me.
So what could you do?
Going from here to here?
Will we average of here
and here is eight okay.
But of course you've co is nine about
nine you've collected $33 don't forget
from your, you're hedging bet.
So although this says nine,
you've got the 33 in the background.
So it's 42 okay. But it's nine.
So what you want to do,
this is not,
you just want to transform this and this
until nine once you've transformed this
and this and to nine, okay?
You, which you can do, right?
Because 60% of this plus
40% of that is nine.
So the other broker is going to,
you can do an offloading hedging bet
with another broker at 60 40 odds to get
nine for sure. Here. Why is that? Because
60% of this plus 40% of that is nine.
Okay.
So therefore there must be offsetting a,
a bad he'd take that gave you nine for
sure in both cases because the offsetting
bet would also be valued at
zero according to 60 40 odds.
So you can transform this
and this and to nines.
But don't forget you've been paid the 33.
So actually this is 44 42 and 42 so you
can keep 42 and 42 going forever and by
the end you'll have 42 forever.
So that's what dynamic hedging is.
It's as simple as that. Okay? Yes.
Yeah.
So how do you make money in a hedging?
You affectively,
we're betting
okay
against the Phillies fan at 50% odds and
you've got your broker who's willing to
give you 60% odds and you're
exploiting that gap. Okay. So let's,
uh, let's do a nother eggs. So, okay,
so it's an excellent
question you're asking.
So I haven't answered this question yet.
I want to give another example
to answer his question. So what,
what is really going on with the hedging?
I mean who, what am I relying on? I mean,
how many brokers do I have to deal
with the hedge, what's going on here?
So I've given an example of a world
series where it's very simple, uh,
to figure out what to do.
So now I want to give an example of a
yeah.
Of A,
um,
yeah.
Okay. I want to give them
that example of a bond.
Okay.
Okay. So it doesn't matter
what bond, I have to confess,
I haven't done this in
advance. Okay. So what is the,
okay, so here we have a, a
year, we have a 30 year bond,
8% 30 year bond. Okay. And it, um,
it's an 8% 30 year bond.
Okay.
Um, it's an 8% 30 year bond. So,
uh,
okay. So we know what its payment is and
now if the guy, if the, if the homeowner,
homeowners are all perfectly perfectly,
you know, uh, not paying attention,
the bond is going to be
worth some amount of money.
Okay. So here are the interest
rates. And I forgot to say,
so we have to assume what the risk is so
we know. So in fact, what does this mean?
We know that the risk is a,
we know that the,
that the uh, risk is a six. The, the,
the interest rate starts at 6%
and it has a 20% volatility.
Okay?
So what does that tell us?
It tells us that the interest rates
could go up or down by this amount.
Now we've assumed that the odds
that it can go up or down are 50 50.
Okay.
So we've assumed that everybody thinks
the odds are 50 50 that the interest rate
could go up or down. That's an
assumption. And so now I'm going to make,
okay,
we assumed that the odds are 50 50.
Let's assume that everybody is
willing to trade you 50 50 odds.
Okay? So what is the,
what is that right? Mean?
This is like your other broker.
Okay. So the interest rate is here,
our zero,
it can go up to our zero times up or it
can go down to our zero times some down.
Okay. And up. Remember is
you know, up by the way,
this equals r zero e to the volatility,
times e to the drift and down equals r
zero e to the minus volatility e to the
drift. It doesn't matter, our
zero can go up or it can go down.
So you as bigger than one D
is less than one probably.
And so we see examples of that.
Now I'm making an assumption here that
the odds are are a half and a half and
that everybody understands and is willing
to bet on these odds of a half and a
half.
So betting on an interest rate move is
called that kind of betting on interest
rate.
Interest rates
means trading,
uh,
interest rate derivatives.
Okay.
All right.
So there are a bunch of ways that you
can trade in the interest rate market to
get a dollar if the interest rate goes
up to this number in exchange for losing
a dollar, if it goes down
to this number. Okay.
And these things are called swaps and
they're called interest rate derivatives
and they're called a whole
bunch of other things, which I,
it's going to take too long to explain.
Okay.
But so let's suppose that you can go
out into the interest rate derivative
market and simply trade a security
that'll pay a dollar. Things go up, uh,
you know, or you can buy another security
that'll pay a dollar of things go down.
Now, what is the price of this
security that pays a dollar?
If the interest rates go up,
let's say they can only go up
or down to one of two values.
So what would somebody,
what would it be? The cost.
If everyone agrees the odds
are 50% of getting out peer,
what is the price today going to be of
getting a dollar if the interest rate
goes up?
Okay,
excellent.
Who said that? Perfect. Okay.
I didn't expect anyone to
say that so fast. So right,
so the,
the pro,
the price here we could write is 0.5
divided by one plus r zero and this price
is going to be going down,
is going to be 0.5 divided
by one plus r zero k. Now,
how did he figure that out?
Well,
the odds are 50% of going up
here on 50% of going down here,
but don't forget you're getting the
money later and this is a one period
interest rate one plus r
zero. So therefore, uh,
what you'd be willing to pay here
is 50% of the dollar that you'll get
discounted by one plus r zero.
What you'd paid here for that is 50% of
the dollar you'd be paid discounted by
one plus r zero. Okay, so exactly right.
But now these are like the
world series game by game odds,
they're going to change depending on where
you are in the tree because if you go
here in the tree,
you've got a higher interest rate.
So it's going to be 0.5 divided
by one plus r u or something,
which is a bigger number. Okay. So
the price of betting on a dollar,
you know what you have to pay to get
a dollar. If interest rates go up,
it's going to be, um, more
here than it is here. Say,
because you're going to still
have 50% chance of getting here,
but you're discounting by
higher interest rates. So, okay,
so this is a slightly Sigler,
but not much.
It's like the broker in the world
series who gained by Game Day by day,
there's the interest rate derivative
market, and they're willing to trade you.
They're willing to let you bet on which
way the interest rates are going to go.
Okay, so what have we got now? We've
got this mortgage that's sitting there.
Okay,
so let's say that you know that the
mortgage is owned by a very rational guy.
Oh,
you know, the mortgage is owned by a
very, you know, the, the, the homeowner,
he's not the owner of the mortgage.
The homeowners are very rational people.
The market is very foolish. This
is an exaggeration. The market,
Mike, thank all the homeowner,
you know, he's got this,
the homeowner's never does anything.
The market things.
So they think the bond is worth
120 but your much, you, you know,
you studied prepayments much
more than the market does.
You realize that the homeowners aren't
going to just sit there, you know,
dumb Lee paying whatever they owe.
If the interest rates go down,
they're going to prepay.
So in fact the mortgage is only worth 98.
Okay.
So the market thinks it's worth a hundred.
The market thinks it's worth a hundred.
The market understands the interest rate
probabilities and is willing to give
interest rate risk.
They agree with you about that.
You don't know anything more about
interest rates in the market. Does.
What you do know is you know something
about the prepayments that the doesn't
know and so you and all the bond is
really worth 98 instead of 120 okay.
So what,
what should you do now?
Let's suppose that the
market is actually treating.
So what the market things market thinks,
market thinks mortgage
is equal to a 30 year bond,
30 year, a 30 year, um, you know,
30 year. Uh, well okay. It's
not actually a bond. Okay.
Cause it doesn't have a principal
at the end. So the market,
so I'm going to have to do a different
sheet here to get it together.
Don't the market, thanks
mortgage, never prepays.
Now let's suppose that what you can trade
in the market is you can trade these
interest rate derivatives. So what
should you, what should you do?
So
what should you do? Now you can
trade the mortgage, you can buy it,
you can sell it short,
you can a buy or sell these
interest rate derivatives.
What would you do?
Let's say you can only buy or sell
one unit in the mortgage. There's,
there's only one mortgage that you
know is training and you want to,
since you know there's a mistake
being made, you're going to,
you're going to use all of it.
So what would you do?
Okay.
Do you think the mortgage is
overvalued or undervalued? Overvalued.
So therefore, what should you do?
Sell all you're allowed to sell.
I've assumed you know,
a little artificially.
All you can do is sell one
unit of the Morgan Short.
So you're going to sell it for $120
okay?
But what does it mean to sell it short?
It means you have to make the payments
that the mortgage is making. Okay,
so you and all those payments are
only worth $98 so what does that mean?
It means that you know you're going
to get a profit of $22 okay? However,
you could get completely crushed if
things don't turn out exactly the way you
thought. So you want to lock
in a constant profit for sure.
So you don't want to get a huge profit
more than 20 and no profit in some other
cases or even a negative
profit and a huge profit.
You want your $22 for sure. So how
would you do that? What would you do?
Yes.
Yeah.
Okay. So let's be more precise.
It's exactly right. Well,
let's just see what that really means.
Okay.
So I'm going to copy these numbers down,
which I can't see yet.
Yeah.
Okay.
So you,
you have a mortgage that's 98 you know,
it's worth 98 something 0.8
okay.
And it could go and the upstate to 92.6
or in the downstate and could go to 99.011
okay? Now on the other hand, the
market thinks that this mortgage
on the other hand,
this other instrument
you're selling at the same time,
something that's worth 120
you're selling it for 120 okay?
It doesn't even matter what the,
it doesn't matter what the mistake is,
the market makes.
That's the reason why the
market made its mistake.
You don't care why they made
their mistake, you know,
they're just willing to give you 124 it.
So you're making a $22 profit.
So what should you do
if you are marketing yourself to market,
what would you do?
What would you mark
yourself to market here?
Well, you've gotten $122 so you've
marked yourself to market here.
You'd say you're 21 point $16 up here.
You'd have to say,
well, you know, you, uh,
you're not up so much money anymore
because you've just lost some of the value
of your mortgage. You've
lost, you know, six bucks.
So you'd have to say you're only up $15
now and here you'd have to say, well,
you made a little bit of money
so you're up, you know, $22 now,
hey,
but you want to lock in this
Prophet 21 point 16 for sure.
So what should you do if you're
marking yourself to market,
you want to turn this money into,
you want to turn this into 21 point 16
but more than 21 to point 16 you want to
turn this into 21 point 16 times one plus
r zero and you want to turn this into
21 point 16 times one plus r zero okay?
Because then having locked in 21 point
16 times one plus r zero that's no risk
and it's got the same
present value is this.
And so every period you want to keep
locking your money into 21.16 that's the
gap between that and up there. Maybe one
six wasn't the right number. By the way.
What was this price appear
that they were willing to pay?
They are willing to pay 120.58
so that's a little bit more,
ah Ha.
That's 21 points seven or something.
So it's 21.7 that was the gap.
So it's 120.58 and so the
gap here is 21.7 so okay,
so you want to turn this
into 21.7 and this to 21.7
Hazel 21.7 here.
You know,
you want to ensure that that's what
you're marketing yourself to position.
You want to know by the
end of the next year,
you could turn this into 21.7
you know, discount it up. Okay.
And then keep a discount
until all the very end.
So whether you take your money now you're
taking your money late or it's always
a sure thing with exactly
the same present value. Okay.
So how would you turn 21.7 knowing that
you're going to run this risk if you're
marking yourself to market,
how would you do that?
Well, you know the value of this plus
this at this interest rate with the in the
mortgage derivative market,
it's worth 98.84 okay?
So you can always transform this into
exactly 91.84 by doing a fair bet.
You can get this to go up to 91.84
and this to go down to 91 point uh
oh there's also a payment here.
Don't forget the payment. So sorry,
we forgotten the payment.
So this is the mortgage as much subtler
because you've actually gotten $8 here
plus eight and this is plus eight. Okay?
So we forgot about this, the president.
So you got an $8 coupon plus what was
left was 92.6 and this is 99.1 plus eight
it's actually the total,
yeah,
value here as a hundred 0.6 and
the total value here is 107.11
okay? And you discount
this by this, you know,
6% interest and you get 98.84 okay?
So,
so I left out a crucial step.
So remember the cash flows.
Here are the coupon plus the
value of the mortgage that's left.
So the value of the mortgage
that's left is 92.65 okay?
Plus the $8 coupons.
So over here you're going to have a
value of 100.6 down here you're going to
have a value of 107 point 11 okay?
So how can you,
you want that to equal locked in forever.
You want that too.
So you know that you've,
you've just sold this mortgage for um,
a hundred. Uh, what do you call it?
A hundred twenties you've
got $21.70 sitting here,
okay?
So now what can you do with this $21.70?
You can cancel your cash flows.
So what you owe on the mortgage
is always exactly the same thing.
98.84 so you want to make this 98.84 so
you have to subtract off something from
here. A hundred 0.6 you have to subtract.
So you want this to be equal to,
so let's do it this way.
Okay,
let's make this 98 point.
There's a simpler way of
saying it. I think 98.84 okay,
so let's turn this thing in.
This thing,
the present value of this and
this is 98.84 therefore, you know,
there must be some fair trade and the
derivatives market that turns this thing
and this thing and to 98.04 times one
plus r zero and this into the same thing,
98.84 times one plus r zero how
do you know you can do that?
Because the present value of 98.84 times
one plus r zero and 98.84 times one
plus r zero,
a half of that plus a half of that
divided by one plus r zero is 98.84 so
therefore the present value of this
thing has to be the same as the present
value of that thing.
And therefore there must be some
trade in the derivatives market.
You can make where you uh,
you sell some of these interest rate
derivatives and you buy some of these
interest rate through it. It was, that
guarantees you 98.84 in both cases.
So that means the present value of what
you have to deliver in cat the present,
the value of what you'd have to
deliver in cash is 98.84 okay,
still $21.70 in present value terms
less than what you've received.
Okay,
so what have you done with this hundred
$20 you've invested that at the same
interest rate and so
now you've got a profit,
you owe 98.84 jacked up
by the interest rate,
but the hundred 20 you've invested,
you've got that hundred 20
plus the interest rates,
you've always got more
that you're carrying on.
Then the present value of what you owe
and you keep going to the end of the tree
when it ends,
you're going to still own 98.84 increased
by the interest rate a bunch of times.
But then the value of the money you
have is going to be 120 increased by the
same interest rate. And so you're going
to end up, um, with money for sure,
which will have a con. So then you can
just reverse it all and get the money.
21.7 locked in for sure at the beginning
and old, nothing later in the tree.
Okay? So to say it all
one more time, okay?
You have to think of yourself
as marking to market.
And if you're marking to market correctly,
you know what you owe is only worth $98
and what you've sold it for is $120.
That's a profit of 21.7.
But you want to make sure you can
maintain the same profit forever, okay?
Or to put it another way,
if you've bought this bond and got those,
if you want to make sure you can
lock in your profit forever. Okay?
So how would you do this? Well, um,
are different ways of doing it. I
was saying, suppose you, you, uh,
so let's say you want this $21.70 for
sure at the beginning and you don't want
to ever have to make any payments on,
you know,
in the end you want everything
to cancel out. What would you do?
How would you do this? Well, this number
tells you you owe in present value terms,
$98.84.
Okay?
So you've gotten a $20.
So with this,
you could take the hundred $20,
put 21.7 in your pocket,
and now with this $98,
you can buy,
uh, these cash flows. What
can you buy? You can invest,
you can invest money so that you,
um,
okay,
you can, you can buy the right
interest rate derivatives,
so you're able to make all the
payments of the future bonds.
So this bond, the actual payments,
the bond is going to make,
you can buy all those payments for $98.84.
Okay.
I guess that's the
simplest way of saying it.
I'm not saying going a
little bit in circles.
What is the mortgage security down here?
If you know how the mortgage
is going to pay, all this is,
is a bunch of payments at
different parts in the tree, right?
It pays $8 here at pays $8 here.
Somewhere low in the tree.
It's gonna just prepay for sure and pay
the whole remaining balance. You know,
down here it's not paying any, you
know, it's just paid off for sure. Okay,
so it's prepaid. So
what is the, uh, sorry,
it's prepaid at the top. It's just
going to at the bottom it's prepaid. So,
okay.
The fact that all these payments together
are worth 98.84 means that by taking
$98.84 in trading on
the derivatives market,
you can buy all those payments for exactly
98.84 so therefore as you go future
farther into the tree,
you always will have the payments
to make you sold the bond short.
What does that mean? Anytime to this bond
makes the payment, the dividend payment,
you have to make the payment, but you
can always buy those payments for 98.84.
How do you know you can buy
those payments for 98.84? Well,
because you know,
by by backward induction here,
the payments are $8 here plus
$92 of remaining payments.
So there's a way in an interest rate
derivatives market of buying eight plus
92.6 that's $100.60 here
and buying 107.1 $11 here.
So by spending this 98.84,
you can get by this many, uh,
interest rate to revolution.
You get a hundred dollars of payments
here and $107 of payments here, you know,
half of 100 plus half of 107 discounted
at 6% interest gives you 98.84.
Okay?
So it's possible on the market to buy
$100 up here in $107 down here with this
98.84. Now out of those hundred
dollars up here you've bought,
give eight of them to the guy
you sold the bond short too.
That's the coupon payment down here.
Give eight of these dollars to the
same guy you sold the coupon short too.
Now that leaves you with
$92 up there and $99 there,
but this $92 is the present value of
what's going to happen next and what's
going to happen next up here is that
you're going to owe $8 to the guy here and
you're going to owe $8 to the guy here,
but what's left and be worth $83 and $97
so therefore with this $92 you in fact
are able to buy this 90 to plus 105 here
because you know the present value of
92 that's [inaudible] 91 you know
almost 90 to plus 105 here is exactly 92
that's how he got that number.
It's a half times this number and plus
the coupon plus a half times this number,
plus the coupon discounted at the interest
rate corresponding to hear that is
$92 so therefore by investing
here in the interest rate market,
you can buy that cashflow here,
the 84 plus eight $92 okay,
pay the guy that ate,
you'll still have $83 left and
what the cash you have over here,
remember you bought exactly this much
cash, you've got this much cash left,
you can buy all the payments you need
to make here the $8 coupon plus you'll
still have 97 left.
So all the way forward through the tree,
you could always afford to buy all the
cash payments of this bond so you can pay
off the guy you sold it short to all
the coupon payments that this bond is
making by having invested 98.84
at the beginning. And similarly,
you've got 120 by selling the bond shorts.
So you've made $21.70 and there's never
any more cash coming out of your pocket,
your pocket to the 21.7 and you invest
in the 98.4 in the derivatives market
over and over changing your investment
and therefore reproducing all the cash
flows that you have to make to the
guy for having sold it short. Okay,
so do I need to say this yet?
I've been saying it for the wealth.
Do How followable with that?
Not Very followable. All right.
Sorry. I didn't do a good
job, so let's try again.
What is the essence of what's going on?
The essence of what's going on is
that gain by gain or month by month.
You can find someone else who will
always trade at fair odds with you. Okay?
Fair odds means in the
interest rate market,
they don't know these people
trading the interest rate market.
They don't understand prepayments.
Okay? It's not like the book he here,
they don't understand prepayments.
They're not willing to bet with you
on what prepayments are going to be.
They're just going to bet with you on
what interest rate is going to turn up.
But you see the cashflows from the bond
depended on prepayments and dependent on
the interest rate.
So you calculated what it was worth,
98.84 because you knew what
prepayments to put in the future.
So if you're absolutely confident
on your prepayments, okay,
you're going to know what this
bond is going to do in the future.
So remember what the prepayment,
you know, and so what is,
what are those prepayments?
It's you know, this stuff.
So down here where the ones
are the guys prepaid for sure.
So you'd have to deliver it to the market,
the entire remaining balance at that
point. But see when you, when you,
when you calculated this bond,
you are anticipating what all
the payments were going to be,
whether they are going to be the whole
remaining balance or just the coupon
taking the present value.
What calculations were you
doing in the present value?
You're doing calculations
that this guy can do.
You're just taking a half times this
plus a half times that discounted the
interest rate derivative.
Guys willing to do that.
He doesn't know what the
prepayments are going to be,
but you're never betting
on prepayments with him.
With the interest rate derivatives guy,
you're just saying,
let me pay you some money now you give
me money if things go up here or I'll pay
you some money ma now and you give
me money if things go down here,
if interest rates go up here
or interest rates go down here.
So because the present value of the
mortgage cashflows evaluated according to
the interest rate probabilities
and discounting is 98.84
that means that you can
successively trade on the interest rate
market and reproduce all the mortgage
payments, assuming you're right
about what they're going to be.
And therefore with $98.84 you
can replicate what the bond,
what the mortgage is going to pay and
therefore you make 21.7 for free because
you sold it for 120.
You only need 98.8 for that to reproduce
all the payments of the mortgage bond.
And how do you know that you can do that?
Because it's just one step
repeated over and over again.
At every step there's going to be a
payment of say $8 and a present value of
what's left. And there'll be a payment
down here of $8 in a present value.
What the floods left.
Or maybe this thing is just uh,
a prepayment which case it's a
single payment of 90, you know,
99.5 that's the remaining
balance after one period. So,
but when you figure out this number,
it's always taken by averaging this
number discounted with this number
discounted.
Okay,
so therefore averaging at the,
at the odds,
the interest rate guy who will give you,
so therefore using this money,
we're now doing the opposite of
the world series using this money.
You can buy this cash,
paint this total payment and you can
buy this total payment because that's
exactly what the interest rate guy.
We'll give you this as equal to a half
of all of that divided by one plus r zero
plus a half of all this divided by
one plus r zero that is this number.
So therefore the interest rate
market by using this cash,
you can buy that and you can buy that
and that's enough to make the payment a
eight that the mortgage is paying. So
you keep your promise. And over here,
if the mortgage prepaid,
you know the remaining balance,
that's that number 99.5 you
can pay that too. And He,
and then the mortgage is done here.
The mortgage is going to go on.
But see it's going on at present value.
You've calculated at 92.6 you bought
92.6 plus eight use the eight to pay off
the coupon.
You still have $92.60 in your pocket here.
You're going to use that to buy
the future payments of a mortgage,
some of which will be a coupon and
maybe this will be another coupon. Okay.
Plus the present value of what's left.
If it goes down to here,
again the guy might prepay but you're
going to have enough money left to make
that prepayment.
So with this $98.84 you just doing
fair rods over and over again,
you're buying the future cash flows and
the mortgage and therefore with $98.84
you can keep all your promises and yet
you've gotten 120 at the beginning so
you've locked it in. Hey,
so that's the, that's it.
Any questions? I don't know if that was
to clear. So somebody asks a question,
you are great at asking questions
cause there is this followup will or,
okay, well that's, it
was too good to great.
Okay.
So let's see if I can do another example.
Um,
uh,
okay,
let's suppose that we've got this bond.
Let's say you can't trade in the interest
rate derivatives market directly,
but you can trade in the bond market.
So let's get more realistic. Now. Let's
suppose that there's a bond market.
Now here we had interest rates of Ah
yeah, we had, okay, so
as a 30 year bond, 8%,
the starting interest rate was six and
the volatility was 20. So we had that,
that a sheet that was bond market trading.
So let's just go to that file was open.
Okay,
so callable bond.
So here we are in the bond market.
So let's say there's a 9% coupon bond.
Doesn't matter what it is.
Uh,
we start at the interest rate of 0.06,
was that where we were starting
and the volatility was 20.
Okay, so here we have the same exact, um,
you've got exactly the same
interest rate processes before.
So those are the interest
rates just as we had before.
Okay. And now let's talk about a
bond. So it's a non callable bond.
I forgot already. Now what I said
how, how long was this bond? It was a,
it was a 30 year bond,
didn't have to be 30 years,
but it was a 30 year,
9% bond
and its value was 140.93 so the bond is
worth 140.93 the interest rates go up,
same interest rate process.
It can go to 121.4
or two 159.4
okay.
So now let's suppose you can't
trade and the interest rate
market anymore.
What should you do now?
Well you've got the interest rate,
you've got the one month bond,
but you can trade at an interest rate
of a 6% and you've got this bond market.
So anyone will buy and sell
with you. This, this is the,
remember this is the 30 year,
30 year,
9% coupon bond.
They're all willing to buy
and sell this with you.
And you've got this mortgage
that everybody else thinks
is the price is worth
120 but you're sure it's worth
98.84 cause you know the,
the prepayments,
the homeowners are smart and they're
going to prepay and no one else realizes
that they're going to do it.
So what should you do now?
You can't trade interest
rate derivatives anymore.
All you can do is trade
in the bond market.
So you do you have any
idea what you could do?
What would you do? So this is um, this
is even slightly more realistic example.
You've got a mortgage that
you know is overvalued.
You've got a bond that you can trade.
And of course you can trade a very
short bond. The one one year bond,
which is trading at 6% interest.
You can trade a one year treasury
and here's the 30 year 9% treasury.
Okay? Which happens to be worth 140. So
what should you do? Well, you know that,
you know,
you could sell this mortgage short,
get $120 for it and you think the value
of the payments is only 98 so you'd love
to do this. The trouble is it, you know,
the future values depend on a
lot of uncertainty. Okay? So,
um, it may be that you'd
have to, you know, you pay,
the payments you might have to make are
more than 98. They could go. So, you know,
so what are you going to do?
How would you lock in your profit?
For sure.
Can anybody figure out what to do?
Just intuitively,
it seems like pretty complicated
to figure out what to do.
So you sell this bond for 120,
you put the $21.70 in your pocket,
you have $98.40 now that you have to
spend to somehow acquire payments that are
going to just allow you
to make the bond payments.
You've sold short the mortgage
payments you sold short and every node,
so you never have to give up any
more money. So what should you do?
You want to acquire some assets with
this $98.84 that'll put you in a position
where you have a hundred point dollars
up here and $100.71 down there.
So how can you do that?
Well,
you have a combination of the short,
you can put,
you have this 30 year bond you
could invest in if you bought,
if you spent $98 on the 30 year bond,
you know that's 70% of that.
So that would give you 84 up
here and 105 down there. Okay,
so wouldn't match what you really need.
On the other hand,
you could also put your
$98 and the one year bond,
which would give you 98.84 times,
you know,
1.06 and 98.04 times 1.06 so you've
got this choice or are you can put,
you know,
you can put $100 here and get $106 there.
Right?
That's what the one year,
the interest rate we said was 6% so that
means there's a one year bond that pays
106 in these two cases,
there's the 30 year bond.
We're $140 could be worth this
and this in the two cases.
So let's say you can't go trade
on the derivatives market.
It doesn't exist but release,
you don't know how to trade on it.
But when you do know how to trade is
on the bond market and the, you know,
the long bond market and
the short bond mark get.
So let's call this the long bond
market and the short bond market.
So what would you do?
Okay.
Any thoughts here?
So let me repeat the problem you find
like you typically do when you were
trained or you know something
other guys don't do.
That's what you're making
your whole livelihood on.
You understand the prepayments are
going to be very fast. They're going to,
you know, the people know how to
prepay the rest of the market.
It hasn't occurred to them yet that
people can prepay there over grossly
overpaying for the mortgage.
Paying $120 so you go and
sell the mortgage short.
Now that means you have to
deliver whatever anyone else,
what the mortgage is pain, you have
to deliver it to other people. Okay,
so that's a lot to take on.
But I say that you can sell this
bond for 120 put 21.7 in your pocket,
take the remaining $98.84 and now by the
cash flows that you're going to have to
deliver in the future, how do you
know you can buy all the cash flows,
their 30 years of cash flows, their
coupon payments, they're prepayments.
There are all kinds of complicated
payments. So the cash flows,
how would those $98.94 you're going
to be able to buy them all. Exactly.
All you can do is trade by the long bond
and by the short bond or maybe sell the
long bond short or sell
the short bond short.
So how by trading these two securities,
can you over and over again can you
replicate the cash flows of the mortgage?
That way you will have hedged out your
risk and you'll have the 21.7 locked in
with ml ever having to worry
about anything in the future.
Provided your prepayment
calculations are correct. You know,
if you're wrong about prepayments then
you're going to be in big trouble.
So you're betting on knowing what the
prepayments are. So what should you do?
Well here, this thing
is going to, you know,
the cash flows at this point are gonna
be worth a hundred 0.68 that you have to
deliver 92.6 for the present value
of the future cash flows here.
They're worth
here or they're worth,
let's just do the real thing.
Nevermind that stuff.
Here are the worth 107 point 11 okay?
Now you know that a half times a half
times one over one plus r zero of 106 plus
a half over one plus 0.06 times 107 is
98.84 so the average of these discount it
is that number. Okay. So,
and you know that the
average of these numbers, um,
so this is the non callable bonds,
so it's not these numbers,
it's this number plus nine and this
number plus nine is paid a coupon.
So the average of these numbers
discounted by 6% is that?
Yeah.
Okay, so, so what does that
tell you should you should do?
Well I cleaned by combining
this bond and this bond,
you can produce a hundred 0.6
and 107 point 11 here. So,
so we know that this top bond is going
to pay you 138.4 up there and 168.4 down
here. Hey, so if you bought, you know,
x units of the long bond,
that's what your pay offs would be.
The short bond is going to pay you 106
in both cases. So if you bought x units,
so the short bond,
that's what your payoff would be.
And you want the payoff to be,
you want the payoff to be a
hundred 0.6 and 107 point 11
hey, so there must be an XL
and an excess that equals that.
How do you know there has to be,
because it's two equations in two unknowns
and these are independent equations.
In fact,
you can tell what Xcel has to be this
gap between a 100.6 no and the hundred
seven that gap is about seven
and this gap is about 38 okay,
so seven is like a fifth of 38 so
Xcel is going to have to be a fifth.
So I know in advance that this is going
to turn out to be about seven over 38
okay.
And XSL just by general principles,
you know there's a solution for
Xcel and access. Okay? Now, okay,
so I know there's a solution to that
because it's too old linear equations in
two unknowns and they're not degenerate.
So I know there has to be
a solution to that. Okay.
And I also can tell you what
Xcel has to be because the gap,
that's a difference between the top
number and the bottom number is seven.
That gap over there is 38 so obviously
the middle gap 160 160 zero so if I take
Xcel to be seven 38th of that number,
the gap is going to go down from 38 to
seven and then I'll just have to find the
right access to make that equal.
Okay,
so that combination of XL and excess,
we'll produce this payoff
here in this payoff there.
Okay, so I know what combination of the
long bond and the short bond to hole.
So I produced exactly these things.
So I'm going to get a cash flow of a,
you know,
a hundred 0.6 and 107 point 11 and I'll
be able to use that to make the coupon
payment of eight and both cases and on
top of that have enough money to continue
buying future cash flows.
Okay.
Now what will the cost of
this l an x a short be?
It'll be XL.
I'll have to pay $100 for
the x for the short bond.
If I do x, x, x, Short,
and I'll have to take seven 30 days of
140 that's almost, it'll cost me to be,
to buy the long bond. So the right
combination of short bond and long bond,
short pond and long bond will give
me the right right payoffs. And now,
uh, and it's clear that there
is an excess here. Okay.
And an XL here such
that I get the payoffs,
I won 100 and 107 but the last thing to
notice is the cost of this XL and this x
s okay.
Which is going to be 140 times
XL plus a hundred times excess.
That cost will be exactly 98.84
okay, how do I know that? And therefore
I'll just be able to do it. Okay,
so I'll ask you that question the second.
So here's,
here's what this hedging amounts to the
hedging amounts to. Again, you know,
because of your superior knowledge of
prepayments, but the mortgage cash flows,
not the mortgage itself,
the cash flows that are going to come
from the mortgage could only worth 98.8
someone's handing you $120 in exchange
for making those mortgage cash flows.
Okay,
so what do you do for that?
You take the $98.84 out of the hundred
20 you take 21.7 that goes into your
pocket, the 98.4 you have to use
to buy the future cash flows. Well,
you know,
the first cash flows are going to be $8
but you're gonna need more money to buy
the cashflows that come after.
How much more money do you need?
92.6 here at 99.1 there.
Okay,
so how can you put yourself in a
position to have a hundred $0.60 here and
$107.11 here?
Can you use this amount
of money to buy these,
this value at the next step? Well we saw
in the derivatives market, yes you can,
but even if you can't trade in the
derivatives market, you don't need to,
if you could trade a
short bond and along bond,
you would just find how much of the
long bond do I hold and how much of the
short bond do I hold so I can get these
cash flows of 100.6 and 107.11 and the
answer is you have to solve
that equation up there,
what Xcel and one excess
gives you that number. Okay.
And that is a,
you know that there's some excel and
some access that will solve that because
it's two equations in two unknowns.
I'm repeating myself.
You even know what Xcel is without
writing down the equations because the gap
has to be, you know, one thing,
there's no risk. And the other thing,
there's a big risk.
So the only risk in the payoff
has to come from the long bond.
So that gap of 38 if you
take seven 30 ace of that,
you're going to get the
gap to go down to seven.
So the XL is gonna turn out to be seven
30 ays excess you have to solve by
Algebra. So you know how much that
Xcel is and what the excess is.
Okay? So that's what you hold.
That combination of XL and excess,
you hold here and you
get exactly the payoffs.
And then the final step is to notice that
you can exactly afford it with $98.84
how do you know that you can afford it?
Because what you want is a 100.6 and
107 point 11 and that costs 98.84 okay?
What you're buying,
you're buying two things together,
which are w who's payoffs together are
worth 98.84 so therefore the cost of the
two things separately have
to be worth 98.84 okay?
So it will turn out when you
fought solve for Xcel and access,
you'll exactly be able to afford
it with this amount of cash. Okay?
And so you can just do that
going forward all the time.
Constantly we hedging your portfolio.
So that's the essence of dynamic hedging.
It's a very um,
beautiful idea, which I probably
haven't explained in the optimal way.
But the point is that, um, to
summarize the whole thing again,
the point is that you take,
you know,
something about a bond but you're subject
to more risk besides what you know,
you hedge out the extra risk,
still relying on yourself
to be right about what,
you know, you relied on your
being right about the prepayments.
You don't know anything about
the future interest rates.
But there's another guy like
the trader in the world series,
the broker in the world series who's
willing to make bets on the interest rate
with you. Okay. Or to say
the same thing. Who's,
who's been calculating the values
of the bonds as if you know,
the short and the long bond as if he
was making bets on the interest rate
because he's calculated at the same 50,
50 odds discounting by the interest rate.
So because there all these guys in the
market who are willing to make these game
by game bets either directly,
I'm almost done there either to make the
game by game bets and the interest rate
directly in the derivatives market
or what's equivalent to that.
They've used that calculus to figure out
the value of these long and short bonds.
So by trading to the long and short bonds,
you're effectively doing the same
interest rate bet. So either way,
by trading through the two bonds are
trading directly in the interest rate
derivative market,
you're able to buy by going
game at a time, year by year,
you're able to buy all the
cashflows of your mortgage,
the cash flows that you're
predicting it's going to have,
and therefore you can make the
profit for sure. Okay. So just it's,
it's a predicting something,
being confident in your prediction than
being able to buy what you've predicted.
The cash flows are for a smaller price,
then you can sell the security for,
that's how you locked in your profit.
Okay.